- You show up at a party
and everybody's like
Hey! Some guy is here in yellow!
And I'm like it's Pikachu!
And they're like barely!
And I'm like thank you.
(upbeat organ music)
- Today we're trying on sexy
childhood-ruining costumes.
- So basically sexy versions
of things for babies.
- Some things just
aren't meant to be sexy.
- It's for children.
- (imitating vomiting)
- We're gonna give some
people some confusing boners.
- Who watches a cartoon
a cartoon and is like,
yepp, I wanna (bleep) that.
- I mean I was sexually
awakened by cartoons.
I don't think anyone wasn't.
- [Voiceover] They're (bleep) everywhere,
they're a nightmare.
- Oh! Minions! These guys are so funny.
- Are they like (bleep)
fire hydrants, right?
- You can't ruin a childhood
that's still happening.
- It's got a chinstrap?
(laughing)
Is this right?
- These feel stretched
out. Has Ned been in these?
- That is a tight minion.
- Off to a good start.
(laughing)
Oh what a mistake I've made.
- If anyone does the Minion voice in this,
I'm going to be very upset.
(unintelligible speaking)
- Oh no!
Aren't these guys like evil?
Isn't that their thing?
- Little ass in there.
- They're just little pill-bugs that hump.
They're like super sexually driven,
this honestly isn't
that dishonest of them.
- I don't know which
way is forward anymore.
- This wouldn't ruin my childhood,
it would titillate my childhood.
(unintelligible speaking)
- Anything yellow that resembles them,
they wanna (bleep) it.
(singing)
♫- I'm for a childhood-ruining
couples costume ♫
- This is a mall pretzel-vendor costume.
- Candy stripers?
- Where do your boobs go?
- Oh yeah!
- Is there such a thing
as camel toe for guys?
- It's called moose knuckle.
- Oh no, this is so horrible.
- Looks like a mean librarian.
- I think I'm more of an Ernie.
- I don't think you're
fitting into these shorts,
no offense.
- No eye holes.
- That just scares me.
- Duck on the butt.
- Rubber duck is so close to rubber dick.
- I'm hiding the letter D.
- I love couples costumes.
Usually go with my wife,
- But,
- could make an exception.
- make an exception.
- This would be really good as a
sexy gay couples costume.
- Yeah it doesn't make
any sense for women.
- Here let's adjust it.
- It's like (bleep) what up!
Let's (bleep) each other.
- Hi-ya Burt!
- Ernie, you smell like liquor.
- I didn't think Burt
ever really liked Ernie.
- He like hate (bleep) him a lot.
- He might as well have
an openly gay, very sexual
couple on Sesame Street.
They already have entire fists
up their butt anyways, so.
- Alright, they're puppets.
- [Voiceover] Pikachu! Oh boy.
- I know this tail,
I had a GameBoy Colour.
- Pikachu is a fearsome character
cause he's fast, but also powerful.
- You're making me a sexy Pikachu?
Is that allowed?
- Cartoon animals are free
game to make sexy, I'm sorry.
I don't care who you are.
- I feel so naked.
- This isn't a costume, it's tubes.
- Oh! This is a man costume.
We're sexy men now.
- We've talked a lot today
about sexualized lady costumes,
but guys also feel pressure to look good.
- Everybody look at my body!
I'm Pikachu or what not,
let's all (bleep) masturbate together.
- I think Pokemon are more fun
to dress up as than trainers
because then you can be creative.
- Pikachu's a pre-teen, his
voice hasn't dropped yet.
This is a sexy 12 year old.
- This is the cutest (bleep) thing ever.
- Pika! Pikachu!
- I'm a (bleep) sexy electric rat.
- Come into my cage, pika pika.
- This is a whole 'nother meaning
of the word Smash Brothers.
- Take a (bleep) Pika.
- Pikachu wanna (bleep).
- You all wanna (bleep) baby rats?
Be my guest.
I'm a sexy baby rat you can (bleep).
- [Voiceover] I'm glad I
can turn some grandma's on.
- Oh! I get to be Cinderella?
Little 'ol me?
- Oh no.
- I'm Belle.
Does that mean my wife is the beast?
- I get to be a villain.
(evil laughter)
- Alright now I'm a mermaid.
- If you were wearing a thong,
this would be a seriously kinky costume.
- Oh damn!
It's getting some dominatrix shit.
- Fairy Godmother made my
dress out of a dish towel.
- She did not show this much leg,
I'll tell you that much.
- That is a titty hole.
- Come on, I can only
wear this until midnight.
- Suck in more.
- I can't, I have a ribcage
like a normal person.
- Do I enter from the bottom?
- Gotta do the bow.
You could fit some boobs in here.
- It makes sense to
sexualize Disney characters.
Oftentimes the sexiest
characters are the villains.
- I am talking boobs.
- Bibbity boppity boobs!
- This is like a cheap, trashy version
of a beautiful ballgown.
- Goo goo gaa gaa, boys.
- I feel like I'm a condom.
- I'm the belle of the ball.
- I just wish they'd give me enough fabric
to cover up this big 'ol pumpkin.
- Bonjour!
- It's gorgeous.
- You want a bite of this poison apple?
- Mirror mirror on the wall,
show me the try-guy
whose skin as pale as cottage cheese.
Hair cover the body like a rabid beaver.
- [Voiceover] Cinderella's whole objective
is I got one night to find a man.
Why not Halloween?
- That'd be a fun costume
if I had my friends dress as
like, sexy woodland creatures.
They sing and they cum on my arms.
(backstage laughter)
- I feel like we ruined a lot
of people's childhoods today.
I mean look at me.
This is clearly a mistake.
- You love your body and
you like showing it off,
be as sexy as you want.
- Just don't do it when
there are kids around!
- If a three year old owns pajamas
with this character on it,
you shouldn't be wearing
it sexy for Halloween.
Just like, come on.
But don't cum on me.
- [All] Happy Halloween!
We're sorry!
- We've done worse,
but this certainly isn't helping anybody.
(screaming)
- Do we have scissors?
- Happy Halloween.